é um prazer estar aqui é por mais que há
18 anos eu trabalho com recursos humanos
enfim é já tenha dado infinitas
palestras sendo o primeiro pede eu vou
pedir para vocês serem generosos e
pacientes comigo é vem falar um
pouquinho sobre o futuro do trabalho que
é um tema que eu estudo já há algum
tempo eu sou hoje do conselho de uma das
maiores empresas de recursos humanos da
américa latina que a companhia de
talentos então estudar o futuro do
trabalho é da essência do nosso trabalho
é eu gosto muito dessa frase que fala
que o futuro já chegou ele só tá mal mal
distribuído e vou contar uma história
bem breve
eu tenho duas filhas a história carolina
elas tem 78 anos e recentemente a
carolina chegou em casa e disse assim
pra mim não tem onde novidade mãe
hoje eu andei de táxi e eu dizia como
fui andar de táxi ela disse nossa mãe
foi muito legal como chama uber estado
táxi e eu disse o baterista do táxi
chama taxista ela foi mãe ele tinha uma
coisa no carro dele que eu nunca tinha
visto antes
é o que ela nem sei explicar para que
vou chamar minha irmã e então ver minha
filha mas é mais velha e me disse que
realmente ela nunca tinha visto aquilo
foi o que era então o que vocês viram no
táxi de tão novo
ela falou não sei o que era aquilo mas
eu acho que o taxista imprimiu o lazy e
fez um livro e eu fiquei bastante
confusa
é um livro ele fez um livro imprimindo
waze é mãe é um livro que se você for no
menu e procurar o nome da rua e abrir a
página tem uma foto do mapa como se
fosse uma foto do e só que estava
impressa entendeu e eu fiquei pensando
sobre essa reflexão e me lembrei que
muito recentemente fui visitar minha avó
que mora no interior e meu tio mudou de
casa e eu perguntei para ela
peguei e falei vou como como o nome da
rua do til paulo e digitei lac que é
isso
eu disse pra ela isso é um guia de ruas
no celular
então entra a minha avó e as minhas
filhas
o conceito
original de navegação já mudou pra minha
avó se navega no guia de ruas das minhas
filhas mas nem sabiam que era um guia de
ruas
então gente futuro já está aqui ele só
tá mal distribuído através das gerações
é e aí eu tenho visto um fenômeno muito
interessante que eu já vi gente que tem
medo de barata palhaço ladrão homem do
saco é mas eu nunca vi tanta gente com
medo de palavras como eu tenho visto
ultimamente toda a gente olha todas
essas palavras né realidade virtual
inteligência artificial genomics quanto
um computing enfim tantas e tantas e
tantas palavras que a gente às vezes nem
sabe o que significa passam a fazer
parte do nosso dia a dia como eu gosto
de dizer é uma tempestade na nossa
cabeça ea gente fica no final das contas
morrendo de medo mas eu queria é convidá
los a gente não tem muito medo né da
tempestade de palavras porque
normalmente quem gosta muito da
tempestade de palavras quem gosta muito
de botar medo da gente são pessoas que
no fundo são vendedores de guarda chuva
então cuidado com o medo dessas novas
palavras e dos novos conceitos cuidado
pra não ter pra ter certeza que eles não
vêm de pessoas que só querem vender
guarda-chuvas pra gente
bom essa realidade que está aí é tudo
isso vai mudar e que não muda nada né
tudo vai mudar daqui pra frente agora
tem algumas coisas que a gente tem a
possibilidade de mudar nós mesmos e som
é sobre essas coisas que eu queria usar
o resto do meu tempo aqui é pra falar
com vocês
a primeira coisa que eu acho que a gente
pode realmente mudar é é a ideia é de
que comportamentos passados nos levaram
até o futuro
a tempestade serve para nos mostrar que
a gente precisa desenvolver novos
comportamentos quando eu olho quando
você olha aí trabalho em equipe o risco
em cima significa que não precisaremos
mais trabalhar em equipe
não significa que a gente vai ter que
dar uma nova dimensão ao trabalho em
equipe e eu chamei essa nova dimensão de
conexão
marcas fortes criam conexão seus
consumidores
mais e mais pessoas estão interessadas
em entender
com quem elas vão trabalhar muito mais
do que elas vão fazer o quanto elas vão
ganhar
no meu entendimento confiança que é a
base de qualquer conexão é a principal
moeda de troca das relações humanas no
futuro é a capacidade de criar conexão e
confiança que vai fazer de nós bons
gestores de pessoas bons gestores de
negócios bons empreendedores capacidade
de se conectar através de uma marca ou
através de um relacionamento com o outro
eu fico muito atenta é muito mais do que
as respostas que as pessoas entendam as
perguntas que elas me fazem e
recentemente mais e mais nesse papel de
articuladora entre o candidato eo
mercado de trabalho eu tenho visto essa
pergunta de forma recorrente com quem eu
vou trabalhar porque trabalhar é
resolver a encrenca
caso vocês não saibam disso ainda há
gente tem talvez o direito de escolher
que tipo de encrenca a gente quer que a
gente quer resolver e principalmente com
quem a gente quer resolver suas
encrencas
então fica aí uma nova conta a primeira
transformação de comportamento de levar
só saí só do trabalho em equipe e entrar
na capacidade de gerar e fomentar e
perpetuar conexões
o segundo é comportamento que eu acho
que merece a gente refletir é essa o
pensamento fora da caixa
quantas vezes por dia a gente não houve
isso fulano pensar fora da caixa tem que
pensar mais fora da caixa
ou seja estou dizendo para vocês que
criar ser criativo no trabalho não é
importante pelo contrário
mas a gente também vai ter que levar
isso pro outro patamar a gente vai ter
que ser capaz de a cada dia não só criar
no trabalho mas criar o próprio trabalho
uma das partes mais importantes de um
processo seletivo é uma descrição de
cargo
basicamente é um documento em que a
gente lá descreve tudo aquilo que aquele
profissional que vai ocupar a vaga
precisa ter conhecer saber fazer
baseado no que é baseada no desafio que
tem aquela posição aquela vaga
recentemente eu tive que escrever uma
descrição de cargo por uma vaga para
trabalhar comigo inclusive foi tão
difícil e por que foi tão difícil foi
difícil porque é uma descrição de cargo
é uma fotografia
ela reflete o que a gente sabe hoje
sobre aquela vaga naquela posição o
ponto é que a gente vive num mundo vulca
volátil incerto complexo ambíguo
então o trabalho certamente vai mudar e
vai mudar muito mais rápido do que a
nossa capacidade de atualizar essa
descrição de cargo
estou dizendo para vocês não façam mais
descrição de cargo de jeito nenhum fácil
pra parar pra pensar naquilo que a gente
precisa mas tenha certeza que era
encontrar alguém que consiga a partir
daquele escopo criar e entender o
desafio entender o problema que está à
sua frente ele vai mudar diariamente e
aí criar a sua própria função criar o
seu próprio trabalho será uma
competência cada vez mais demandado e
por último eu queria falar um pouco é da
análise né quem já ouviu falar de círio
othon alexa
sim com certeza todos nós já ouvimos um
case já ouvimos uma anedota
já ouvimos uma previsão sobre como a
inteligência artificial irá substituir
os humanos
a verdade é que essas máquinas seja ela
se o hodgson o alexa e muitas outras que
eu nem sei o nome certamente farão
análise de dados muito melhor do que nós
farão não já fazem o outro já ganhou da
gente no xadrez voto já ganhou da gente
no japão ele e todos os outros jogos que
envolvam armazenamento e correlação de
dados provavelmente os computadores vão
ganhar da gente
no entanto os computadores não são
capazes de fazer uma coisa muito
importante que será cada vez mais
importante que a capacidade de refletir
eu tenho a dizer que talvez 90% dos
problemas que a gente tem hoje como
humanidade não são problemas técnicos
são problemas éticos eu imagino que a
gente já tenha condições hoje de
produzir e distribuir comida o
suficiente pra ninguém mais no mundo
passa fome
a gente não tem um problema de produção
e distribuição a gente tem um problema
de responsabilidade pro atlético
a fome na áfrica subsariana é problema
de quem
essa é a pergunta que a gente não
consegue responder porque se a gente
quiser alimentar o mundo inteiro com a
tecnologia de produção e distribuição
que a gente tem hoje a gente consegue
a gente tem capital a gente tem terra
fértil a gente tem tecnologia que já foi
para israel
absolutamente incrível que se produz no
meio do deserto
então a gente é capaz o problema não é
técnico o problema é ético moral e
responsabilidade
estava conversando recentemente com
filósofos e ele me disse que o que
salvará os humanos pense bem olha que
interessante não é a nossa consciência é
a nossa inconsciência é tudo aquilo que
está aqui no fundo da nossa mente e que
hoje a gente não precisa se preocupar em
acessar
por que por que o mundo pede da gente
por enquanto a análise mas daqui a pouco
e cada vez mais é ser a reflexão
falando em reflexão é e recentemente fez
uma mudança na minha carreira eu pedi
demissão para mim mesma
na companhia de talentos como executiva
continuou como acionista no board e foi
trabalhar em outro lugar e muito
interessante que esse processo começou
com uma reflexão esse processo depois de
18 anos absolutamente dentro da minha
zona de conforto como se o melhor lugar
que muita gente quer chegar
eu comecei um processo de pensar o que
eu estava fazendo ali e paz nem esse
processo aconteceu é numa conversa na
copa do meu escritório
eu sentei para usar sem tomar garota
minha frente eu vi que ela era nova
porque nunca tinha visto era por ela por
ali e ela me perguntou a oito do bem que
se faz aqui não me faz me fala você o
que você faz aqui que eu nunca tive por
aqui lá eu atendo candidatos
eu acho interessante eu também tenho
candidatos e eu fui pra faz quanto tempo
que está trabalhando aqui ela faz dois
dias
eu falei aqui é isso que está gostando
do trabalho ela tomou gosto do trabalho
ela falou eu falei mas quando você tem
ela ah eu sou menor aprendiz
eu acho que então seja muito bem vinda e
ela de mim mas se não me falou do que
você faz e eu fiquei pensando como é que
o explico por uma menina de 16 anos que
nunca trabalhou
o que faz uma se o então eu resolvi
simplificar e disse para ela que eu
fazia um pouco de tudo
eu atendia candidatos que eu estava na
área financeira que eu falava com
clientes e aí ela virou pra mim uma cara
assim que entendeu muito bem o que
estava falando e disse então já sei o
que você faz você é assistente geral e
eu fiquei pensando e eu disse exatamente
isso que eu faço humanos e definiu é
definiu o meu papel e eu fiquei pensando
muito né sobre sobre o quanto a gente
tende a sofisticar o que dá uma
importância muito maior para aquilo que
a gente faz e no fundo um se ou que se
preze nada mais é do que um assistente
geral
dois dias depois eu fui na reunião de de
escola das minhas filhas
acabou a reunião a professora da minha
filha mais nova disse pra mim então
maíra você trabalha em telemarketing né
eu não tava em marketing não tem nada de
errado com trabalhar em telemarketing
mas não é o que eu faço ainda onde você
tirou essa idéia é que o trabalho de
telemarketing eu perguntei para carol
carol respondeu que trabalhava em
telemarketing ela falou não falou que a
sua mãe faz ea carol disse minha mãe faz
kols ea professora disse que são roubos
ela eu não sei eu sei que ela tem um
forninho assim ó e ela fala no
computador o dia inteiro é e aí a
professora deduziu entendeu então que
era telemarketing flu telemarketing é
isso mesmo que minha mãe faz
e aí eu fiquei pensando de novo né sobre
a natureza do meu trabalho e eu passo
gente boa parte do meu dia no telefone
eu falo com clientes avaliou projetos
enfim
no fundo no fundo no fundo o que eu faço
mesmo é ser um assistente geral e
telemarketing
se eu é só um nome sofisticado é e
bonito que a gente tende a inflar a
nossa própria resistência à e aí desde
então eu venho fazendo um processo de
quisse de fato o cargo
o título o nome não importa o que
importa então né
é eu não acredito que existe
infelizmente apesar de adorar o harry
potter eu não acredito que existe que
exista varinha mágica para a vida que a
gente vive aqui nessa terra mas se
existir ou se a gente quiser inventar
uma varinha mágica para viver aqui
mundo eu diria que é a capacidade de
aprender a aprender a ideia de que nós
precisamos aprender todos os dias o dia
todo não só numa instituição como essa
dentro de uma sala de aula mas a em
absolutamente tudo que a gente faz
eu aprendo roriz com minhas filhas eu
aprendo com a menor aprendiz que acabou
de chegar
eu aprendi no táxi eu aprendi assistindo
séries e eu aprendo lendo livros
assistindo aulas é fazendo cursos desse
jeito tradicional que a gente sempre
aprendeu isso continua tendo valor mas a
idéia de que a gente precisa realmente
para ter uma chance
nesse futuro dominado pelas palavras que
nos amedrontam dominado pela capacidade
de análise das máquinas
a gente precisa ter a capacidade de
criar o nosso próprio trabalho criar
conexões refletir e aprender
absolutamente todos os dias e aí por
último pra gente e encerrando é eu gosto
de poesia escrevo e leio muita poesia e
ultimamente eu tenho é tomada liberdade
os poetas já estão todos mortos quase
que o link acho que eles vão ficar
chateados de hackear os poemas hack as
crônicas que eu leio e dar uma nova
interpretação para isso então eu escolhi
um poema do victor hugo que eu gosto
muito é que chama de desejo que eu
peguei um trechinho e fiz uma adaptação
aqui pra para esse momento que a gente
está juntos com a esperança de criar uma
conexão com vocês estão victor hugo diz
assim desejo outro sim que você tenha um
ego forte porque é preciso ter força e
coragem e que pelo menos uma vez por ano
coloque ele o seu ego na sua frente diga
você é meu
só para que fique bem claro quem é dono
de quem no poema original ele fala sobre
dinheiro que também vale pegar um pouco
de dinheiro no final do ano está em cima
da mesa e dizer você é meu mas eu acho
que a busca não saudável por dinheiro é
no fundo é um desdobramento do ego
descontrolado então de tudo o que eu
vejo nesse mundo que o trabalho é que é
o mundo do trabalho né com a
oportunidade
relacionar com mentes brilhantes no
brasil e no mundo todo eu acho que essa
talvez seja a única grande armadilha que
pessoas brilhantes realmente podem ter é
deixar é passar a acreditar que o ego é
seu dono
passa a acreditar que o ego tem que
nortear suas ações enquanto que na
verdade a gente não pode perder a
capacidade de refletir e de entender que
nós são os donos dos nosso dos nossos
egos e eles têm que estar a serviço da
gente e não o contrário
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]